that cake every day taking care of
business [ __ ] where are we going to go
get there 1p success new in town a here
for the future now my armor from old
place isn't your you're under arrest oh
[ __ ] anything why never saw miss ring
before in my entire life we can do this
one of two ways you can walk off a short
[ __ ] I can drag your life is funny
your choice but I'm very well yep fine
jewelry here by some armor and live to
tell about it okay okay
the rat way okay Manny's place a trap
what the [ __ ] penny it's the [ __ ]
block they say yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I hate hard oh I'll be
back yeah I'll be back fat chance fetch
catch someone there thank you Wow take
some of that a thank you baby the
nightclub
set
chase s
those days are over I'm telling you well
well Calum and Pratt what I wasn't
certain I'd ever see you again shut the
[ __ ] up betch reliable song meaningful
now that I've whetted your appetite with
on ship the oro I want you to explain to
that piece uddhava do this right and I
can promise you a permanent time I
honestly but that is secondary here
right a word of warning though I don't
want any of them you going on you if you
need any details on your marks I'll be
here so I'll get going ok what's the
easy way out of here
he's our way out of here oh there we go
where are these [ __ ] and I'll take
too kindly to people that are they
running
now
rabbi
and how got let me just make sure it on
my sword equip if you what did you want
what if you want now I only explained to
him that you can't get blood from a
stone look I can't make the corn appear
out of thin air and so have you can't
scare me with your tough talk i'm not
paying you people a single coin after
all you want you can't squeeze blood
from a stone not in this part of the
world anyway I'm big this never should
have come here okay too yeah yeah you
have committed crimes against Skyrim and
hurt people what's save you in your
defense Martin [ __ ]
if you're looking to settle in risk them
there's a house for sale funny job so I
hear you yell says my skill in battle is
unmatched fortunately for you that skill
can be bought let look like talget my
food is oppressed in almost I ask all
you want you can't squeeze blood from a
stone not in this part of the world
anyway ask all you want you can't
squeeze blood from a stone help me I
didn't think you had the stomach for it
why do you ask all you want you have
committed crimes against this guy i'ma
nerd people not me what's in you in your
defense if I ordered up the yarn stop
right there ask all you want oh [ __ ]
they [ __ ] me up wait I know you aah
ask all you want you can't squeeze blood
from a stone not in this part of the
world anyway
ask all you want you can't squeeze blood
from a stone not in this part of the
world think you can fight the order of
the yarn stop right there Mark's man now
come along with us she says what's funny
why are we yelling Imperial stick so
lawless be okay so it's all night
Yuda stranger here too huh you look like
you could use a drink what do you say to
some cheap meat shape man so can I
interest you in anything today
that's what I just get hurt by Chet
so can I interest you in anything today
catchy isn't it in my youth I ended up
if I had been smarter I would have kept
my sobrinos doesn't even bother to show
up itself any you're gouging me for what
little coin I make don't fool yourself
it's only a mat I'm going to make you
sorry for this come on never should've
come here oh you make them fight you
first [ __ ] you're not that is a please
no Lord I say oh there we go here I hope
you're here for friendly a reason no
okay so you just got to make them fight
you Jesus I don't have to [ __ ] it
here we go here we go if your allegiance
lies with the Empire we haven't much to
discuss here for a room or something
I've already told that buffoon that I'm
not look around you I'm barely keeping
distance come on give it your best shot
high five
if I get best again that's right lizard
hey take it sorry your name okay now
where's that [ __ ] that sent me to jail
like 10 times get that [ __ ] right now
if you please don't hurt me I know who
you are you've been Tara please there's
no need for that here message understood
here I even have the payment look I got
the message what else did you want just
leave me in peace oh sure keeping this
place clean [ __ ] hot a [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] hot can't even think she
was so hot
yeah cats go it's a rat away [ __ ]
items
ok
here we go what is that dog I didn't
kill that I don't know her dad what it
was in may okay
so jobs done and you even brought the
gold best of all you did it clean I like
that dumping bodies and keeping the gods
quiet can be expensive well done here
you go I think you'll find these quite
useful again again judging from how will
you handle those shopkeepers I'd say
you've got that's the spirit I think
you'll do more than just fitted watch on
your mind we've run into a rough tell
you what you keep making us clear enough
that show more question how about
following me and I'll show you what
we're all about thank ya